are you starting a trend are there are
other people that are following your
footsteps now actually what do you think
I think probably yeah you think yeah you
honestly think that yeah I think there's
probably some people that look at what
you're doing and young kids that think
it must be you know I here's what I
think most people look at the path that
the average person takes in life you
know onna sell cars I'm gonna be an
insurance guy and they look they look at
it like it's deaf if they look at a kid
a young kid who's like enjoying playing
with his friends or doing sports or
playing video games or reading comic
books and then you look at what could be
the average path that the average person
takes in life and sitting in an office
all day under fluorescent lights it
looks like death it looks like a slow
aching death but then I look at someone
like you I'm like wow this guy is living
of special life this is a special life
we're so ideally though somebody would
look at it and see that like this is
somebody living a very intentional life
or having chosen a certain path yes not
necessarily free selling I mean I would
love to inspire people to live an
intentional life that they care about
yes I don't necessarily feel like people
all need to go free so lorg right well I
think that's that's a very good way of
describing it and very good way of
putting it because I think you most
certainly have influenced people in that
regard but I think also people must be
influenced in in the sense that they see
what you're doing is man there's moments
that you must experience while you are
climbing these incredible faces that are
kind of magical when you're up there
you're a thousand feet up there the view
is [ __ ] spectacular and you're doing
it and you get to the top of these
things though the rush and the feeling
of accomplishment and the euphoria and
just the glory of nature from the
effective yet I look at this whoa you
could [ __ ] wash your clothes on the
sweat that's in my hands right now man
that's a [ __ ] pictures insane we're
looking at it what is the the name of
this photo Jamie it's the Endura corner
come on cab
that's actually that's the movie poster
dear man so may so that that that is not
sitting in a cubicle that is not
fluorescent light with that that is the
end of a very long path that you have to
choose and really cultivate you know I
mean that's that's for me 23 years of
sort of going in or 22 years there's
something of going down a very specific
path